si son 267 los
157 el proyecto de ley está aprobado
para la cámara de representantes de eeuu
le dio el visto bueno a un proyecto de
ley que busca proteger los matrimonios
entre parejas del mismo sexo y parejas
interraciales a nivel federal una
decisión impulsada por la mayoría
demócrata y apoyada por 47 republicanos
y que se enmarca como un intento de
proteger otros derechos luego de la
derogación por parte de la corte suprema
del mundo versus white que garantizaba
el derecho de la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo en todo el país un
precedente que para muchos ponía en la
cuerda floja varias libertades estamos
aquí porque hace sólo tres semanas la
corte suprema controlada por los
republicanos a nuevo roe versus way
arrancando la libertad de una mujer
sobre sus decisiones de salud más
íntimas debemos actuar ahora para
defender el matrimonio entre personas
del mismo sexo y el matrimonio
interracial de la intolerancia y el
extremismo
la casa blanca celebró el resultado
ninguna persona debe enfrentarse a la
discriminación por ser quien es o por la
persona a quien ama y todas las parejas
casadas en eeuu merecen la seguridad de
saber que su matrimonio será defendido y
respetado pero el camino para su
aprobación deberá superar varios
obstáculos el más grande de ellos ser
validada por un senado dividido en
partes iguales entre republicanos y
demócratas
allí necesitará 60 votos a favor